BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
Good morning.
Everyone looks up from
their tablets.
This is great.
Yeah, thank you guys
so much for coming.
We were a little worried Friday,
midday, either you
guys are all over hungover from
last night or just came
here for breakfast.
So this is great.
I'm Bridgette Sexton.
I work on the Global
Entrepreneurship Outreach Team
here at Google.
I've been at Google for about
years and focused on a lot of
different things, aka not
focused too much.
I worked in advertising, and
then actually spent two years
working on our emerging markets
team in Ghana, and
focused on Sub-Saharan Africa.
And I've spent a lot of time
at Google traveling.
I think I hit my 50th country
last week, which is a little
exhausting I still
look this good.
It's a joke, you guys need
to work on this.
JON BRADFORD: You're
allowed to laugh.
These are jokes.
So our team--
lots of people ask about global
entrepreneurship, what we do.
We really focus on developing
ecosystems around the world.
There's a question from the
earlier session about Mexico.
How How do we actually develop
our ecosystem there?
And the guy said-- one of the
panelists up here said, it's
all about having good leadership
on the ground who's
investing and building that
infrastructure and building
that community.
And we're very, very privileged
and lucky to have
five of those such people on
this panel with us today.
I've pretty much interacted
with most of these people
through a lot of Google's
projects and partnerships that
we do globally in the
entrepreneurship space.
Looking at, how can we help
with partnerships, and
products, and also with our
Google-specific programs to
encourage entrepreneurship?
And particularly, startups.
UPS
I'm actually going to
introduce each of our panelists.
The format is basically
we're going to have
some discussion here.
These guys are quite lively.
We've had a pretty hilarious
morning already.
So feel free to ask
questions as well.
We're going to have
about 15 minutes
at the end for questions.
So please keep them.
If you can, even write them down
so you're ready we have
that set up.
So with that, we have, on my
left, Jonathan Bradford.
Brad Is your name Jonathan
or just Jon?
JON BRADFORD: Well--
sorry.
Everybody awake?
It's Jon and/or Jonathan
depending upon
whether you're my mother.
So I prefer Jon.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: So Jon is
actually the founder of
Springboard, which is a
13-week Accelerator
program in the UK.
He's actually helped found 13
Accelerator programs around
the world, from Moscow all
the way to Montreal.
And he personally runs five of
them, which I am not sure how
he does that since I mostly
see you at conferences.
And he is actually a former
accountant, which we are not
going to hold him to today.
JON BRADFORD: Bad.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yeah,
it's pretty sad.
JON BRADFORD: Bad.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Eden is a
general manager, general
partner at Genesis, which is
an Israeli VC in Tel Aviv
that's focus on early
stage investment.
He has had a number of good
exits, we'll say.
He's been founder of
a few companies--
face.com, Aternity.
And recently started an
incubator called The Junction
in Tel Aviv.
And then we have Jehan, which
she is part of Pasha, which is
Pakistan-focused IT education
and training program.
And they work to develop links
internationally for Pakistan
in the tech community.
She's had 29 years of experience
working in this
field, helping bridge the tech
community in Pakistan to
places like Dubai, Hong
Kong regionally and
the Valley as well.
She's a huge advocate for
entrepreneurship and
technology development
in Pakistan.
Erik Hersman, the guy
with the big, red
daunting beard over here--
he's much friendlier
than he looks.
You guys are a really
tough crowd.
He's co-founder of Ushahidi,
which is a
crowdsourcing platform.
Many of you have probably
heard of it.
He started the iHub, which is an
innovation hub based out of
Nairobi, Kenya.
He grew up in Sudan and
Kenya, has been a
long time in Africa.
Although his Swahili is not that
good, which I found out
last night.
And he's a senior TED Fellow
and is currently raising a
fund focused on technology
startups in Africa.
Jeffrey Paine is the founder,
one of the founding partners
of Golden Gate ventures based
out of Singapore.
He's focused on early stage
investments across the region
of Southeast Asia and also some
up into the rest of Asia.
And he's also one of the
founders and managing partners
of Founders institute
and has helped that
grow across the continent.
And also, a long-time VC.
So please welcome me in
joining our panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: All right,
so we're going
to get started here.
In 142 characters or less, tell
me what is unique about
your market, your home market.
Starting with you, Jon.
Jonathan.
JON BRADFORD: Jon.
Definitely Jon.
Interesting statistic: London
has 260 nationalities in it.
The next largest city in the
world close to that is New
York, which is 150.
It's a massive, massive
melting pot.
And it's got great
entrepreneurial visas for
those that are interested.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Eden, what's
unique about your market?
EDEN SHOCHAT: Anyone here from
Israel, so I'll know whether--
OK, we do have.
Bridgette asked for
a great statistic.
So just the funny statistic is
that the general time to an
exit is 5.8 years.
Average marriage in
Tel Aviv is 5.
Anyways.
So the interesting thing about
Israel, I think it's a very
small country.
Depending how you count, it's
six, seven million people.
Virtually almost zero
local market.
We don't get along too
well with our region.
So there's no regional
market either.
So every startup from
the get-go is
international in nature.
The stats are you have about
40,000, 50,000 engineers
working at any given point at
about 2,000, 3,000 startups.
So basically, the issue, if
there is an issue in Israel
about entrepreneurship, it's
mostly that everyone wants to
be an entrepreneur, and
does not want to
be the first employee.
So that's the biggest
problem that we want
and that we're tackling.
Israel is the third largest
country in the NASDAQ.
So we actually get many
companies out, IPO
[INAUDIBLE].
So we are very international in
nature, and I think that's
pretty unique about
the country.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yeah, you've
expanded your character limit.
Jehan?
JEHAN ARA: OK, we have 187
million people, 60% of them
below the age of 30.
We have only 25 million internet
users, but we have
about 120 million mobile
subscribers.
So I think that, in itself,
is a great opportunity.
Many of the people who have a
mobile device or a mobile
phone have never
had a landline.
And the country is vast.
The youth bulge is an
opportunity, and yet can also
be a challenge.
So many of us realize that there
will never be enough
jobs for all the people that
we have in the country.
And it's growing by about
4% every year.
So we're going to have many more
people before we stop.
And so we need to create
entrepreneurs.
And I think everybody in the
country realizes that.
And so I'm very passionate
about doing what I can to
increase the number of
entrepreneurs in Pakistan.
ERIK HERSMAN: So though I live
in Kenya, I'll speak for
Africa as a region, which
is always a mistake.
But I'll try anyway.
So we have a billion people
in the continent.
And we have about 140 million
internet users,
which isn't very big--
14% of the population.
And then the phone penetration
though, is
north of 700 million.
So over 70% mobile phone
penetration.
So it shouldn't come as a
surprise to most people that
about 96% plus of all internet
traffic goes through the
mobile phone.
And so the paradigm in Africa is
mobile first and everything
else would be second.
JEFFREY PAINE: Hi.
Just show of hands, who is
from Southeast Asia?
OK, great.
So I'll speak on behalf
of Singapore.
Singapore is also a very
small country.
Our local domestic market
is very small.
So in Southeast Asia, the
population is around 620
million, which is fairly massive
if you really count
the countries that are opening
up, like Myanmar right now.
It's pretty interesting.
Indonesia has just
over 250 million.
And I think, as of last month,
the first ever $40 US Android
phone has come out from China.
So what's going to happen?
I think in general, in Southeast
Asia, the mobile
penetration will keep going and
the PC penetration will
also keep going.
So in general, mobile
penetration is always roughly
around 50% to 70% and PC
penetration is always below
50% for emerging markets.
Take aside Singapore, Singapore
is a bit crazy.
So it is extremely interesting
right now for Golden Gate.
We have investors from the
Valley that is interested in
Southeast Asia because it is
showing signs of early stage
China and early stage Vietnam.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Thank
you so much, guys.
So now we're going to move
into a round of specific
questions for each of them.
Eden, you've had
many successful
startups, a lot of exits.
And also, a lot of investments
in the region.
What made you start
The Junction?
It's kind of co-working
incubator space, why didn't
you start that in Israel,
the Startup Nation?
EDEN SHOCHAT: So part of the
ecosystem in Israel in the
'90s, I think a major part of
'90s and early 2000 was
telecom type companies, security
type companies.
Very strong back end processing,
mostly resulting
from the Israeli army.
I'm not sure whether you know
we have mandatory service in
Israel, so 18 to 21.
And the good news is that there
are the intelligence
Corps units that actually
train some of the best
computer scientists worldwide
in actual
mission-critical systems.
So that actually created awesome
companies that came
out, but the army doesn't do
e-commerce or mobile much.
So there are certain things that
you don't get trained as
well, which are now the biggest
potential growth
engines for pretty
much any startup.
So when I moved over to the dark
side, as some would say
of VCing, I thought what you
just need to modify, is find a
way to invest in early
stage startups.
So syndicate, make sure that
money is readily available,
get great deal flow.
So just the basics of
venture capital.
The truth was though, and I
think that's part of the
ecosystem of any international
country right now that wants
to create those kind of startups
is there weren't good
consumer-oriented startups.
They were sporadic.
There was no information
sharing between them.
And they just couldn't do what
you can do in Silicon Valley.
So The Junction was kind of a
prototype that we thought, how
can we get better companies?
So there are just three
questions that you get asked
before joining.
The first one is,
are you working
on the venture full-time?
The second one is, is
the entire team
going to work together?
And the third one is, are you
willing to work 90% of your
time on your own startup and
10% of the time on other
people's startup that are
siting just next to you?
And surprisingly, not many
people actually answer yes to
all of these.
But once you do answer yes,
you actually create an
interesting critical mass.
And that's what The Junction
is all about, .
it's creating a pay-it-forward
economy where
we don't take anything.
As a VC we can take a very
long-term look, so we can look
10 years ahead.
And we don't care about
short-term revenue.
So what we actually
do is we don't ask
anything from the companies.
And in return, we ask them
to help each other.
So the gist of this is, The
Junction is all about to
create that kind of
companies, the
consumer, the B2C companies.
Which, I believe, is a huge
opportunity for any
entrepreneur outside
of the US.
What you care about in a B2C
company is analytics, funnel,
things that everyone is familiar
and you can get all
the resources that you want.
Even outside of the Valley.
But to achieve that,
you actually need
to create that ecosystem.
And The Junction is
all about that.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Cool.
Thank you.
I think Jon's been working in
this field for a while--
12, 13 Accelerator
programs now.
What do you see these
guys producing?
What has surprised you about
working with all these
different programs globally?
And do you think any of them
are better or worse, any of
these particular ecosystems
you're working with?
JON BRADFORD: So the one thing I
personally and very strongly
believe is no particular country
or geographic region
has a monopoly on
entrepreneurs.
I believe that there's a
balance, there's a proportion
that exists that mad, crazy
people who want to do stuff,
which is totally irrational and
start their own business
when the chances of ever
achieving are nil, are the
same the world over.
The subtle differences in
certain other geographic
regions, they may be
doing other things.
And one of the things that I've
discovered is, actually
if you give them the tools and
the support from the community
and other entrepreneurs, you can
kind of guide them down a
path which is what I
call product-led.
So moving away--
[INAUDIBLE] recently
in this room.
But in the world I exist in, I
see a lot of people building
stuff for other people,
service-led stuff.
It has no impact.
It's unscalable.
You can't export it.
Or if you do, it's really
difficult to create any value,
or meaningful value.
What I've noticed is in all of
the countries I've worked in,
as I described from Montreal to
Moscow, entrepreneurs exist
and they have the same passion,
and the same hunger,
and the same desires.
They just want to find soulmates
to work alongside,
which is kind of what's being
achieved in Israel.
And when you give them
that opportunity,
they run towards it.
And they run toward
it really quickly.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: I almost made
a dating reference there
from the soulmates comment,
but I held back.
You guys are a really tough
crowd, actually.
JON BRADFORD: Yeah.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: We've been
warming up all morning.
JON BRADFORD: Yeah, the
other one I actually
use is fellow travelers.
That's the big advantage that
Silicon Valley has, is there's
so many more fellow
travelers who are
moving in the same direction.
That doesn't necessarily mean
that you can't achieve that in
other places.
It's just you have to create
critical mass around something
to make it happen.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yeah,
I definitely agree.
You know, Jeff, you've done
a lot of investing
in Southeast Asia.
And there's not as many
incubators and Accelerator
programs as developed.
What are you guys investing in
at Golden Gate Ventures given
that every country has its own
culture, every country has its
own language, and it's
very segmented?
And particularly, without kind
of these ecosystems as quite
as evolved.
JEFFREY PAINE: Right.
So basically, Golden Gate
Ventures, we look at more
towards consumer-facing
companies.
So we do look at mobile a lot,
consumer internet, games, and
also software as a service.
What's been challenging is
obviously within a four-hour
flight, you get to see many
countries, different
languages, different cultures.
Singapore is a developed
country.
We are right smack
in the middle
of developing countries.
And we kind of get along
with them quite well.
I think, yeah.
So the challenge is
a few things.
Number one, they tend
to think very small.
So division-wise, it's
fairly small.
They tend to think very
local or hyperlocal.
They need to be a little
bit crazy.
And what's also missing is a
layer of mentors that have
been there, done that.
And not been there, done
that 10 years ago.
Been there, done that within
five years because technology
changes so fast.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Jeff, can I
ask you, what's your latest
investment?
And why?
JEFFREY PAINE: Sure.
So I think, let's see.
The latest one was sort of
an enterprise company.
They do flight operations, ERP
for small aviation companies.
It's pretty interesting.
They originate from Malaysia.
But they have client base
all over the world.
So that's kind of different
in that sense.
They go global from day one
because they know if they go
hyperlocal they will die.
They don't have enough
money to survive.
And in general, in Southeast
Asia, maybe in the other parts
of emerging countries,
there is a pressure
to make money fast.
To survive quickly.
So sometimes innovation
takes a second seat
to surviving quickly.
JON BRADFORD: I actually would
disagree with that.
So one of the things that
actually gets pushed really
hard around in Europe
is the fact that we
get to money faster.
Because there's less capital
in the market, we actually
have to go and say, well, do
customers want to actually pay
real, cold, hard cash
to make this happen?
And a really good example of
that is Huddle, which is based
in San Fransciso are split
between London and the Valley.
Just closed out at
$23 million.
But they aggressively
went after--
forget the bloody
freemium model.
It's like somebody has to pay
me cash to make this happen.
And actually, in smaller--
whether it's restrictions around
capital, I actually
personally think that
that's a good thing.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Erik, you've
been working in a very early
stage market, many would say.
What's the technology
ecosystem?
What are you talking
about, Africa and
the technology ecosystem?
Is that even possible?
And you started iHub, which is
a technology innovation hub.
And you're also working
on a fund.
I'd love to know what the role
of iHub is in that community
and what you're looking at--
and you start to raise
this fund as well.
ERIK HERSMAN: So we first
started the iHub because we
had this really--
we did have a vibrant tech
culture in Nairobi, but it
wasn't centered anywhere.
So people hardly met.
And so we thought, well, what if
we just built a place that
we could call our own, have a
coffee shop in it, and guys
got to hang out?
So we have over 8,000 members
now all from Nairobi, about
95% from Nairobi.
And what they're doing is
they're just getting together
and meeting.
And so a lot of people
say, well, what's the
value of the iHub?
Actually, Google Africa is
based out of Nairobi.
So Google Africa is
a partner of ours.
And I remember going and seeing
Joe Mucharu who was the
Africa director at the time, and
talking to him about this
place and saying, hey, we
need your support here.
And he and his team
they said, so--
being Google.
So how are you going
to measure success?
And we sat there, we were like,
we don't even have paint
on the walls yet.
And we're thinking.
I said, well, we think if you
just put enough smart people
in a room, good things
will happen.
And so after about a minute of
quiet, everybody looks at each
other and starts smiling and
saying, OK, well, we'll back
it anyway, even though
we don't really
know how it will work.
And the truth is you have to
experiment things when you're
in a new market like this
because there's just no way to
know what's actually
going to work.
So getting a bunch of smart
people in a room did work.
We have about 45 companies have
been kind of born out of
it over the last two years.
Some of them have
failed already.
Some of them have gone on
and gotten more funding.
Some of them have actually
gotten funding from Bay Area
VCs and are getting bigger.
So when you're in a new space
like that, in a nascent
market, you're building
everything.
You actually are building the
market many times, itself.
Which is exciting, but it
has a lot of challenges.
And for us, it's really just
about bringing people together
and seeing what happens.
And then going onto the seed
funding side, which is what
we've done with the
Savannah Fund.
Is just saying, can we apply the
Accelerator model that's
from the Bay Area, from
Europe, something
like that, to Africa?
Will it work there?
Again, an experiment.
We'll find out.
We have about half the fund
raise right now and we'll find
out by probably this time next
year how well it does.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: If anyone's
interested in writing checks,
you can see Erik after this.
EDEN SHOCHAT: Actually,
Bridgette said not to talk
about the specific event called
GeeCON, which we're doing.
Or not to turn the panel into
a discussion about GeeCON.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Eden's
passion is
actually really in GeeCON.
So if we let him, he
will [INAUDIBLE].
If you guys want to riot at some
point, we're OK with it.
EDEN SHOCHAT: So anyway,
it's a three-day event.
And Google is sponsoring it, so
I'm actually allowed to--
it actually gives something
back to Google.
But I would very much agree with
the point that you need
to create critical mass.
I think I've heard three times
already that word mentioned.
And it's all about being able
to create those teams.
The question is, in every
country is, how do you create
those teams that they'll be able
to do something together?
The most important thing for
every entrepreneur is to be
able to convince the team
members that they actually
should be doing whatever that
he thinks or they think that
they should be doing, and way
before they have funding.
So when you actually have that
burn rate, when every month
you have a reduced amount in
your bank account just because
you're doing your passion.
And the question is, how do
you build those teams?
That's a huge question
in every market.
GeeCON as a three-day event,
just brings people as the
hardware, and software, and
art, and just get them to
build stuff.
There's crazy stuff.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Do you want
to tell us what the
purpose of GeeCON is?
EDEN SHOCHAT: Oh, yeah.
The purpose is to create
useless projects.
So think--
no, no, and that's the
actual definition.
Because people are so much more
creative when they are
told to do something that is
not meaningful versus--
OK, I have the socially
acceptable.
I need to make money.
I need to do something else.
So things like a trampoline
that you jump and your
silhouette becomes your
login password.
So if you want to get back to
your PC, you need to jump
exactly that same way again.
Which could be productive
in some fashion.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: It's a
weight loss program.
EDEN SHOCHAT: Weight
loss program, yeah.
Or really, really crazy stuff.
But from that, you actually had,
as of last month, seven
teams that started companies
as of right now, about 11.
So it actually had
a good success.
And that's the basis, in my
mind, to just starting things
up, is critical mass.
ERIK HERSMAN: Just a little
thing to kind of
pivot off that, too.
I think here in the States--
I lived in the States for
about six, seven years.
And it's interesting because
here in the States it's
socially acceptable within the
culture for you to wear jeans
and a t-shirt and be at work.
And that could be at
a coffee shop.
But in Kenya, or in many places
in Africa, if you don't
wear a suit and tie, you don't
go to the city center, you're
family doesn't consider
that you have a job.
And so it's really difficult.
You have to create this culture
about it being that
you do this other
kind of stuff.
So I guess we're a little bit
further down the stack than
some other countries.
But it's really interesting to
see how you can build that
kind of a culture out in
whatever part of the world
that you're in.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yeah, I always
love when people come
to Google in suits.
It's like the first time anyone
feels so awkwardly
dressed up at a business
meeting.
JON BRADFORD: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE]
actually wrote a really
interesting essay on startup
cultures and communities.
And actually, one of things he
described in that essay was,
how do you make being an
entrepreneur really cool and
being the most normal
thing in the world?
And the problem is,
entrepreneurs exist, but
they're such a minority within
the overall population.
When they actually all clamber
together and work alongside
each other, they can, as
I describe, stare at
the window and point.
Look at all those weird
people outside.
They work for other people.
And it's kind of that notional
idea of turning something
which is considered unacceptable
culturally in
certain instances, into just the
most normal, boring, this
is what we do.
This is the coolest stuff
in the world.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yeah.
And that's actually what Jehan's
trying to do right now
in Pakistan, is create the
culture where entrepreneurs
are celebrated.
And you've actually been
running a fund
for the last year.
I've love to hear-- it's the
Social Innovation Fund focused
on these kind of social
impact startups.
Can tell us a little bit
about the impact of
that fund so far?
JEHAN ARA: OK.
So historically in Pakistan,
the tech sector has
concentrated on building
applications
for people with money.
So mainly for the financial
sector, whether domestically
or internationally.
But there are a lot of problems
within the country
that need to be solved.
And many of the young people
living in the country know how
to solve those problems.
What we did was just to open
their minds to the fact that
you can do it using
technology.
And so Google helped us, seeded
a fund in Pakistan,
which is $250,000 fund.
And we've been managing
it for the last year.
The reason that it was needed,
sometimes I don't even think
you need money to start
working on an idea.
But these young people at
universities and fresh
graduates think that without
money you can't do anything.
So we figured, OK, let's get
rid of that mindset and
actually give them the money.
Actually, what they need is
guidance, mentoring, helping
them sort of put a
team together.
Because very often what happens,
and I think this
happens all around the world,
is geeks who work together
sort of try and put together a
team without having anybody
with any business knowledge,
or anybody with
any marketing knowledge.
And so they create things that
they find exciting, but they
don't know what the consumer
will like.
And so with the Social
Innovation Fund what we've
done is we ask for ideas
and we got--
within the first week, we had
300 people sort of write in
with ideas that they thought
were really cool.
And we chose--
our jury actually chose five of
those ideas and said, OK,
we'll fund this but we will
attach it with milestones.
And we will attach them to
mentors who will guide them
through the process.
So we know that many of them
may fail, but that failure
will teach them a lot.
Some of the ideas that
came out was--
that you may not even consider
social innovation.
So one of them was the
resurgence of the national
language, Urdu.
Because many of us think it's
cool to speak English and so
we're forgetting our culture,
we're forgetting our heritage.
We don't know all the
literature, the rich culture
that exists.
And so two of the young
people said, we want a
resurgence in this.
And the reason that kids prefer
not to speak in Urdu,
or not to read Urdu literature
is because it isn't cool.
There's nothing innovative
that exists.
There's nothing that you can
download onto your iPod, or to
your mobile phone
and listen to.
And so they started recording
some of these stories, and
some of these songs, and some
of the poetry onto these
devices and making it
downloadable from a website.
And that has created a lot of
excitement, not only in the
kids within Pakistan, but
amongst expat Pakistanis in
the US, in Europe, et cetera,
who think that the kids and
losing touch with their heritage
and their language.
So that was one.
Another one was that there are
several diseases still in
Pakistan that may have
been eradicated
all around the world.
And blood is often needed,
blood donations.
And it's very difficult
to find them.
And sometimes it's really
critical that it be found
immediately.
So this one young man who has
a network of about 200,000
already on social media said,
I know all these people.
I'm going to create something
using technology which will
connect blood donors to
hospitals, and to people who
need blood.
And so he's working
on that project.
And already, we had a Dengue
attack where he was able to
connect people to blood donors,
and was able to save a
lot of lives.
So those kind of projects, I
think, are helping kids not
only solve problems for the
community, but they're also
getting them to think about how
to take a project from an
idea stage onto an actual
implementation stage.
And then they can work on
commercial ideas using the
same logic.
So I think that it's really
amazing what it has been able
to do so far.
We've funded about five ideas.
Only About $10,000 each.
And we're looking at funding
the next five
within the next month.
The first year was difficult
because we were sort of
learning as we went along.
But now we think that that
process will be accelerated.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yeah,
I think it's amazing.
Something I'm always struck by
now living in the Valley and
then still getting to travel
a lot is, actually a lot of
startups here--
no offense--
are actually just creating
features.
And another thing for
me to log-in to that
I'm going to forget.
And I'm going to type that
little forgot password thing
every single time.
What I've found in a lot of
the emerging markets and
internationally is people
are actually
trying to solve problems.
And there is actually revenue
behind many of these
opportunities.
And a social focus, or actually
solving a real
problem can create sustained
revenue.
You're not going to be pushed
out of the market quite as
easily I think.
JEHAN ARA: So one of the things
that we haven't funded,
but that has also started off
as a social idea, but has
being able to generate revenue
for the people who started it
is something like
what happens--
what already exists
in Kenya is the
M-Pesia Branches Banking.
In a population of 187 million,
we only have 20
million who have
bank accounts.
So how do the rest
of them operate?
They don't seem to have any way
of transferring funds or
paying for things.
And so Easypaisa is a solution
that came on
and they have been--
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
Great naming.
JEHAN ARA: Yeah.
What they do is enable payments
through a mobile phone.
And it's a very easy process.
And every kiosk selling
cigarettes or anything is a
certified Easypaisa vendor.
And all you do is show them an
identity and should give them
their mobile number, and they
can transfer the funds to
somebody with another mobile.
So 120 million people having
access to mobile
phones, it sort of--
suddenly everybody has that
power of transferring funds,
paying for things, paying
utility bills, all that.
And it's a very easy solution.
It's a social solution.
And yet, it generates revenue
for the people who funded it.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yeah,
it's great.
I think one thing you
mentioned is around
milestones.
And I was talking with these
two, I think two days ago, and
you guys were mentioning that
you like to do really small
seed investments, and lots
of them despite how
much work they are.
Something along the
milestone marker.
Why do you do that?
Why do you do a lot of small
seed investments despite the
amount of work?
JON BRADFORD: Because
I'm not lazy.
So I used to be a VC,
as I described for
about 3 and 1/2 minutes.
I used to do a lot
of seed funding.
I had this really weird thing
that happened, which was the
smaller the investment, the more
progress the teams made.
When I wrote them a big check,
they bluntly [INAUDIBLE] where
am I. They didn't progress as
well as they should have.
They spent more time
concentrating on product and
not enough time spending with
kind of customer-facing time.
When I wrote people really
small checks, I suddenly
discovered the first thing they
did was they went to see
a customer.
That creates a massive
amount of work.
I mean, our friend Mr.
McClure knows what
that now looks like.
Seemed like a good
idea at the time.
And we've done something very
similar in Bulgaria,
interestingly alongside
Google.
But we've just created
a 12 million
euro fund as I describe--
and I'll get shot for this when
I get back to Europe--
it's a desert.
It's an absolute desert.
There's no funding.
And there's lots of smart
people, but they just don't
know how to get started.
In the next three years we're
going to fund 200 teams to
start their businesses.
Or actually, take their ideas
or products, make
real things from them.
We expect a massive amount
of fallout of that.
But that's essentially what you
guys have been doing for
the last 30 years.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: So you're
going to lose Google's money
is what you're saying?
JON BRADFORD: You didn't
put any money.
JEHAN ARA: Can you bring
some of it to us?
JON BRADFORD: No.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: This is the
way you get positive PR, you
give everyone tablets and
phones, and-- just kidding.
JON BRADFORD: No.
EDEN SHOCHAT: Aren't we
getting enough shit?
JON BRADFORD: Yeah.
You don't have to go through
customs and explain what all
this stuff is.
But essentially, I will
swear now, so I
apologize in advance.
The approach is throwing a lot
of shit at the wall and seeing
what sticks.
And in markets where there are
limited funds available, it's
better to try and to not
succeed, but at least try.
I have also this big thing
about what I call the
entrepreneurial compost heap.
I don't know whether that
translates into American.
But essentially, if you take a
very gardening analogy, you go
through and you weed, and
you take stuff out.
You don't throw it over the
fence, you stick it in a
compost heap.
And then you mulch the plants
and the rest of
the garden as well.
So actually, what you do is you
embrace failure and you
say, actually, just
because you failed
doesn't make you bad.
But what we want to do is you've
learned a whole bunch
of really interesting stuff
because of that.
We're going to feed you
back into the system.
So when the stuff that actually
works really well, it
takes hold much stronger because
you're retaining the
talent, the experience, and the
knowledge that you gained
through not just the successes,
but the failures
that you have.
Where you can build cultures
which embrace that attitude,
where you want people to try.
And even if that ultimately
leads to failure, the fact
that you push it back into the
system and say, that's not
socially unacceptable.
That's actually much smarter
because we want to try and do
something to actually make it
better and to actually help
the ones that do take root.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Eden, in
Israel there's lots of money,
lots of capital flow there.
And you probably have a lot of
opportunities for series A,
series B investments.
Why are you doing seed?
EDEN SHOCHAT: Who here
took VC money?
Raise your hands.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: [INAUDIBLE]
who want some,
see Eden after this.
EDEN SHOCHAT: I think it's
an important distinction.
So the one thing that you need
to figure out, and part of the
basic issue is, the way that
the VC system works is that
you actually need to deploy a
good amount of capital because
your LPs, your limited partners
are looking for a
specific return.
So if you run $100 million fund,
you're expected to give
back about x3 returns if
your fund is good.
Now x3 returns, that's
$300 million.
Generally, a VC would own about
25% of the company at
the point of exit.
So that means that you actually
need to generate $1.2
billion worth of value to return
to your LPs the kind of
returns that they're
expecting.
Which is virtually impossible
if you do not deploy
significant amount of capital.
So if you deploy $100,000,
which I just did
in an awesome company--
we haven't announced it yet.
But basically, you take three
pictures of your legs or of
your feet and you can then
generate insoles for it.
Just internet based insoles.
Which I needed insoles for
like three years, but I
haven't done that because you
need to go to a doctor and
measure your feet.
And so this guy just
needed $100,000.
But if you think about that, the
VC model, say I now get a
significant return on that.
He sells his company, instead
of $1 million worth, he's
selling it for $10 million.
The amount of money that I, as
a VC, just made is almost
ridiculous.
It's not good for
my [INAUDIBLE].
That's why VCs don't do those
investments other than buying
options, which I strongly
advise you not to.
For a variety of reasons, all
of them are the internet.
Now, I think the model needs
to be different.
And I encourage you to also do
that in your local groups by
not giving away money,
or giving
$20,000, that's the same.
But my perspective is
don't take anything.
Give them the value that
they can use in order
to build that company.
So if you need a place to sit
for three months, six months--
hey, get that for free.
If you need to have the
information that you need of
what it means to-- what a cap
table is, or other such things
that you must be educated about,
just get that for free.
If you need connections in
Google, Twitter, Facebook, or
whatever, get that for free.
Basically, reduce the cost of
entrepreneurship in those
critical customer development
six months cycles.
Give that for free and
just make sure
that people fail fast.
If your idea then actually
sticks, if it makes sense,
then you can raise the
A rounds, et cetera.
And as a VC, in my VC hat, we
can give you that money.
But to create a community,
to create an actual
infrastructure in every country,
every even city or
state in the US, right
now you have Mecca,
which is San Francisco.
You have a few other, like
New York is finally
becoming like that.
But in every state that you
are coming from, I would
encourage you to try to build
those groups and reduce the
cost of entrepreneurship.
And that's what we
are trying to do.
And then, if we can make money
off of it, that's great.
But the reason why I'm doing
that, and the short answer is
just because you
can build that.
You can actually create-- you
can make a difference.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Cool.
I'd love to switch
to another topic.
So we have this whole
idea of mobile
tablets, is it a desktop?
Is it a PC?
Is it going to be your laptop?
Is it your iPad?
Where is this next wave of
technology for your region?
And tell me why.
And we're going to do
in like a one-minute
sort of rapid fire.
So we can start with
Jeff at the end.
I mean, mobile?
JEFFREY PAINE: Yeah.
From where I'm from, I think
mobile is the number one thing
that's growing right now.
For a certain segment of market,
I think the iPhones
are still the sort of--
something that people
aspire to have.
But what we are seeing
is Android is taking
over Asia big time.
So Japan is now already--
they don't build the [INAUDIBLE]
phones anymore,
it's all Android now.
China has their own versions
of Android that they built
that is much interesting
for Chinese people.
Some of you from China, you
probably have seen them.
And the cheap manufacturers from
China are churning out
really, really cheap handsets.
And that's going to be flooding
India, Middle East,
and North Africa.
And that will certainly change
a lot of things.
But that's one think, that's
just the device, right?
The next thing is the data.
So that is still a little
bit nascent.
They have the device.
They kind of know that
it's cool looking.
But then when they want to
switch on data, they kind of
like, OK, I have to pay.
Majority of the markets are
prepaid, so they get a little
bit stuck when they'll like,
oh, I have to pay for this?
So they kind of get stuck.
So some emerging countries
and the mobile
operators are pretty--
they take risks.
So in Indonesia, they are kind
of quite cool in taking risks.
So what they do is they
will package a
mobile phone and a plan.
And then they'll tell
you there's
three apps on the phone--
Facebook, Twitter, and
[INAUDIBLE], which is the
local regional mobile
social network.
If you use that, the
data is free.
So that creates a ton of people
using social media.
And when you meet these people,
when you ask them,
what is Facebook?
They will just show you
the app in the phone.
That's it.
They have no clue what or where
Facebook come from.
This is Facebook, right.
So that's very interesting.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Jeff, do you
have any suggestions for
developers, maybe looking
at Asia as a market?
JEFFREY PAINE: Yeah.
So if you're building games
right now, I think Japan is
interesting.
China is also interesting.
There's over 100 Android
app stores in China.
I think the top 20 you can kind
of find them, and then
get them to market it for you.
But I think if-- a lot
of you are Android
developers I take it.
It's a very, very good
place to be.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Erik?
ERIK HERSMAN: Yeah.
So most people think that
we don't have any data
connectivity in Africa.
Or very limited.
You think maybe it's edge.
The truth is I can get off the
plane in Nairobi and have
better 3G connectivity than I
can when I get off the plane
in San Francisco.
And that goes up country
in Kenya as well.
So it's not just in the city,
in the capital city.
But it's also in the towns and
cities across the country.
And this is actually quite
common in a lot of countries
across Africa.
So there's a lot of preconceived
notions about
what technology in Africa
is, and where it's at.
And it's usually not true what
you've been hearing.
M-Paisa was brought
up earlier.
So obviously it's mobile in
Africa, I said that earlier.
The biggest mobile payment
organization in
the world is in Kenya.
We move more money.
1 out of every 25 mobile
payment users in
the world is Kenyan.
We move 25% of our GDP through
mobile payments.
And it's the only--
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: I think
it's every day.
Actually, almost every day.
ERIK HERSMAN: It could be.
Yeah, it's like $1.4 billion has
been moved as of December
of this last year.
So it's a lot of money going
through the system.
And the interesting thing about
that is if you think
about it, who's really
innovative in the US or in
Europe on mobile payments?
Well, not very much, actually.
Most of it's just a new skin or
face paint on credit cards.
It's in places like Kenya.
It's in places like the
Philippines, where you're
seeing really new forms
of money movement.
Where it has nothing to do
with a bank account, has
nothing to do with
a credit card.
The only thing it has is air
time, or just agent to agent
kind of money, or person to
person kind of money movement.
And this is phenomenal.
There's a groundbreaking kind
of innovation happening in
places that are well
at the edge.
While everybody's paying
attention to the US, or
Europe, or Asia, sometimes
there's things happening in
places like Africa that are
really shocking that
Microsoft--
shocking them, too.
But shocking the Visas and
Mastercards of the world.
So I think you can look at
Africa and you see mobile, and
you can see new things happening
there that you won't
find anywhere else.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Great.
Jehan you want to start?
We're actually going to start
questions here in a minute.
So if you guys have questions,
please feel free to line up
behind the two mics here.
JEHAN ARA: OK, so in Pakistan
I think mobile definitely,
much like Africa.
It's the way that we're going
and it's the place we are at.
Voice activated, any kind of
applications that uses voice
or SMS is working
very well there.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Do you have
any great local apps that are
really strong in the markets?
JEHAN ARA: One of the problems
that developers in Pakistan
faced was market access because
of the negative image
of the country.
5% of the narrative of Pakistan
is spread around 95%
of the time.
But the online stores, like the
Google store and the App
Store, Apple App Store, has
meant that it doesn't matter
where the app is develop.
As long as it's good,
people like it.
They download it.
So some of the top apps on the
BlackBerry store have been
from Pakistan.
And they've been there for--
they've been productivity
apps.
They've been gaming apps.
Some of the top apps, top 10
Apps on the Apple store in
terms of games happen
from Pakistan .
And even in China, there have
been millions of downloads of
some of the games that have
been developed there.
So that's pretty exciting
because young people who are
fresh out of university, maybe
two years out of university,
and they're developing games,
and they're selling them and
making millions of dollars.
One of our guys actually, during
his holidays, decided
to build an app because it was
a problem that he was facing.
And he built an app and
it was selling for
$25 on the App Store.
$25 a download.
And he sold a million.
He is certainly one
of the richest
young kids in the country.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: It's probably
quite cool to be an
app developer now?
JEHAN ARA: Yeah, it is.
Now everybody wants to
be an app developer.
And now you've got to figure
out what app works.
And not all games work.
So that is the challenge right
now, that you've got to find
ways of educating them.
I think one of the biggest
problem is I wish there were
many more of our young
developers here at I/O.
Because the excitement, the
energy of this conference, and
the passion that they have,
mixed together they would have
learned so much.
They need a little bit of
polishing and that's it.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
Yeah, I agree.
JEHAN ARA: They're some of
the smartest kids there.
And it's just the opportunity.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Eden, I'm
going to change the question
slightly on you.
In the mobile space, what
are you investing in?
I mean, what's hot for you?
EDEN SHOCHAT: So it's almost
a given that mobile is the
computing platform today.
Anything else is marginalized.
So that, OK, we're done.
The exciting thing about trying
to invest in what will
be big three years now
is you see a lot of--
you see the beginning,
but a good portion
of augmented humanity.
I'm not sure whether it's
a commonly used term.
So Google Glasses is
a good example, a
very initial example.
I haven't seen actual
information being projected
into it, so I'm suspending
my disbelief.
But that's augmented humanity,
to improve us through the use
of computing, and bring
that information in
an always-on basis.
There's another company that
are actually very cool.
Think of in-ears, like
for deaf people.
But right now for the general
population that you can
actually play with your
Android, or iPhone, or
whatever and say, I want to
hear what these guys are
talking about just five meters
away towards that direction.
And you're hearing--
it's a DSB on top of that,
that actually has you--
you can cancel noise or hear
anything 5, 10 meters away.
So that's, in my mind--
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Not
creepy at all.
EDEN SHOCHAT: A bit.
But the point is of using
technology in order to augment
very basic capabilities.
So right now that's one of the
most exciting areas for me.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
Jon, one minute.
JON BRADFORD: Very quickly.
JEHAN ARA: That will
be a challenge.
JON BRADFORD: So this
is a shameless plug.
We believe so fundamentally that
mobile is important that
we've actually launched
an Accelerator
only program for mobile.
So go and apply now, Springboard
Mobile in London.
We've got some awesome visas.
Which basically means I can
actually [INAUDIBLE].
Forget about UK border
authorities, if you get past
me, you and a founder can get a
three-year visa potentially.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: And
you're Irish.
JON BRADFORD: Yeah, I'm Irish.
So I mean, I have a really big--
this is a really big
thing to me.
So there are now technically
more arm chips in the world
than there are physical
arms on the planet.
We are just about to hit
the fifth generation of
computing--
blah, blah, blah.
It's mobile computing,
it's not mobiles.
Every time you step down
in computing world from
mainframes, to minis, to
workstations, to personal
computers, the number of devices
increases and the
geographically disparity
increases massively.
So this is, as I described,
not about West Coast,
latte-sipping surfer dudes with
iPhones, this is actually
a massive, massive market.
And it's going to exist
everywhere else apart from
California.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Wow.
California as an island.
OK, let's start taking
a question over here.
If you can introduce yourself
very briefly, and then try to
keep your questions
quite brief.
JASON: My name's Jason, East
Coast entrepreneur, a
technologist.
And my wife has been
to the developing
world several times.
It looks like our careers
will take us there.
JON BRADFORD: By the way,
everybody's developing.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Well, some of
us actually aren't, which
is the problem.
JASON: So my exposure, as
someone who's grown up in the
states of the developing world,
is someplace where
infrastructure is--
my preconceived notions of it
are that they're not as firm
as they are here.
So it's hard enough in United
States to get a company off
the ground as
technology-oriented without
having to worry about, is the
power going to be on?
Is the ISP going to be up?
If my vendor leaves me high and
dry, can I take them to
court and get a civil action and
get my compensation back?
Can you talk about strategies
for US-based developers to
sort of get involved in
developing companies in
developing nations where those
things that we take for
granted her aren't a given?
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Erik, do you
want to talk about that with
[INAUDIBLE]?
JEHAN ARA: May I address that?
OK, so we have lots
of power issues.
We've got, in certain parts of
the country, security issues.
But generally not.
I mean, it's perceived
to be that.
And we've solved them.
Aren't entrepreneur supposed to
find solutions to problems?
That's what we've done.
So most people now have
either UPSes on
which their power runs.
It doesn't matter when the power
is off, the UPSes run
them, the generators.
We forget about the fact that
the infrastructure will be
given to us.
We've created it ourselves
because we know we cannot
survive unless we have
these devices.
Now, the current new devices
which are coming with longer
battery power are helping us.
So I think as long as there is
an entrepreneur, any problem
that exists, actually they look
at as an opportunity, and
they look at as a challenge, and
they find a solution, and
they just move on.
So a lot of companies now-- it's
hardly ever known, but
one of the companies that
emerged out of Pakistan was
actually bought by the
Carlisle Group here.
It was a financial services
company for $100 million.
Several others have
just been sold.
There was a gaming studio that
has had an investment of $35
million from Japan.
So they're small companies, 20,
30, 100 people, who have
created businesses.
It's the front office that needs
to be outside because
they need to market
themselves.
And that's begun to happen.
So if you're thinking of
investing in Pakistan, believe
me, there's a friend of mine
who graduated from
Stanford, went back.
He said to start a company here
it cost him $2.5 million.
Took him 11 months, failed.
Went there for $60,000,
he started a company.
It succeeded because there's
so many opportunities for
creating new applications, new
solutions, and you've got a
big market.
And anything that works in
Pakistan, works in India,
works in Africa, works
in the Middle East.
So you've got a huge market
available to you.
And you can try out ideas
for as little
as $10,000 to $15,000.
If you fail you try
another one.
And so you've got the talent
there, all you need is to use
it and not be afraid to--
as Jon was saying, if they fail,
that's the beginning of
the next success.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: I'm going to
move on to the next question.
JON BRADFORD: Can I quickly
jump in there?
Who's planning on taking
a holiday this year?
Nobody?
Right.
When you take a week
off, go and travel.
And go and see the world.
And see what's actually
happening outside of the US.
Actually, only 10% of Americans
have passports.
That's really sad.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Over here.
AUDIENCE: So this is a question
about Southeast Asia.
I run a US-based startup
that was introduced to
Asia late last year.
And we're doing very, very
well over in Asia.
We, in fact, now have a office
based in Singapore.
And we focus on large enterprise
corporations.
And I was just wondering if you
had any advice for a US
company that's expanding into
Malaysia, Thailand,
Singapore, et cetera.
What are things we need to watch
out for and how do we be
successful?
JEFFREY PAINE: Sure.
So the easiest port of call
is Singapore because for
Americans it's kind of like
California but hotter--
all the time.
Lots of great foods, so you'll
probably put on weight.
JEHAN ARA: He says that
without smiling.
JEFFREY PAINE: So start with
Singapore, depending on how
you want to do it.
The good thing about Singapore
is there's a lot of enterprise
salespeople you can hire.
Because we have grown up to be
educated to work for big
companies from the
US and Europe.
So there's a lot of people with
very good corporate sales
experience.
So that's a good
thing for you.
Especially if it is very
enterprisey, like many months
of sales cycles, that
kind of thing.
And then regionally,
same thing.
All you need to do really is
to hire one guy that has
regional experience.
Just one guy.
That might take a while.
But once you hire him, he will
bring the rest of the team in.
JEHAN ARA: Or her.
JEFFREY PAINE: Or her, yes.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Or her.
JEFFREY PAINE: Usually.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Question
over here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, quick
question.
So have you seen companies that
have expanded into other
countries do better by just
essentially translating the
languages on their existing
apps and taking it there?
Or actually, redoing the
entire UI design
to match that culture?
And then have you also seen
people who attack smartphones
rather than smartphones and
dumb phones essentially do
better since they're
such on a rise?
How have you seen smartphones
rising in
your individual countries?
JON BRADFORD: Who has Instagram
on their phone?
Have a look at the interface.
There is no language
on it at all.
When you start shrinking things
to mobile devices, it's
icon-led as opposed
to language-led.
So your ability to move things
between geographical or
cultural differences are
minimal on my end.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: We actually
don't have any more time for
questions, unfortunately.
But these guys are going to
be here in the outside.
I actually have one last
question for each of you--
30 seconds.
I want to know what keeps you
passionate about the markets
that you're working in,
the ecosystems that
you're working in.
What keeps your passionate?
What's the next thing for you?
JON BRADFORD: Entrepreneurs.
EDEN SHOCHAT: Beautiful.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: That's the
shortest answer I've ever seen
Jon give in my life, except,
would you like a beer?
Yes.
EDEN SHOCHAT: Beaches, beautiful
women, and the Tel
Aviv spirit.
Anyway--
no, but seriously, you should
come to Israel.
But what keeps me up--
so I'm still at
2:00 AM, just looking--
I'm waking up, looking at
executive summaries.
I think just the talent and
just the originality.
I learned that I'm old
when I thought ring
tones won't work out.
And that is now a $5
billion industry.
So it's great to see new
people with new ideas.
And that's really
a huge driver.
JEHAN ARA: OK, I grew up in
Hong Kong and I moved back
about 15, 16 years
ago to Pakistan.
And I choose to be
there, although I
could be anywhere else.
And what keeps me there is the
passion, the excitement in the
young people, the energy, the
need to want to prove
themselves.
And I think if I can contribute
even 1% towards
their growth, towards their
success, towards their
believing that they can do
anything that anyone else in
the world can do, then I think
I'm doing something right.
ERIK HERSMAN: There's a lot more
friction in a place like
Africa, but there's also
a lot more opportunity.
And it's great to see kind of
a community get-together and
grow something, grow a whole
market, grow a whole industry,
to build a foundation for what's
going to actually be
affecting the continent in
the next 5 to 10 years.
So just being a part of
that is why I do it.
JEFFREY PAINE: For me,
I echo this a lot.
I am very sort of privileged
to have to do what I do.
It's really remarkable to help
crazy people change the world.
I'm just amazed that I'm
paid to do this.
So if you guys have that
passion, just go for it.
There will be people that will
be standing behind you.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Thank
you guys so much.
I think this is really one of
the most exciting times, if
not the most exciting time
to be an entrepreneur.
If we look at technology, the
technology you've seen the
last three days, the barrier
to entry is very, very low.
You no longer have to be sitting
in Silicon Valley.
And in fact, some of the best
entrepreneurs that I've seen
in the last few years are not
sitting here and doing
phenomenally well.
And building things that we
might think are US because we
download them off of our
Android, or iPhone, or iPad,
or your new Android tablet.
But really, they may have
been created in
Pakistan, or Kenya, or--
JON BRADFORD: Finland.
Rovio.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: --potentially
those UK people.
And I think that these guys
have definitely taken the
bootstrapped approach to their
economies and to their
particular ecosystems.
And I know many of you guys--
actually, how many of you are
from international markets?
That is awesome.
I think many of you guys have a
chance to definitely be much
like them in taking advantage
of creating an ecosystem.
All of their programs are
actually available and open to
a global audience.
And I have seen a huge value in
people taking their startup
and going to a new market, or
going to a place that's a bit
foreign, finding talent, and
being in one of these
ecosystems.
So if you're interested in
joining an Accelerator program
or sitting in the iHub, there's
some huge textiles
companies have actually moved
themselves to Kenya, who I met
in the iHub.
I think there's enormous
opportunity.
And I can't thank you
guys enough for
coming to share that.
So please help me welcome-- or
thank the crowd here, thank
the audience, thank the
panelists for coming.
[APPLAUSE]